those in our aviation services who were
denying responsibility they were saying
this based on their findings and I
repeat they are not to blame it is us
who are to blame the plane was on its
way it did not have any error or mistake
everyone worked very well efficiently it
was us who made a mistake and we are
responsible we should accept
responsibility and accountability this
was a very small missile that's why the
plane had the time to sort of land and
to crash it did not explode straight
away so they were not aware I did not
know to defend them so our military
forces neither the IRG was aware about
it but we are regretful and we also are
in pain and we share the pain of those
families who lost their loved ones so
basically this happened due to the
heinous activities of Americans that
night we were ready to confront in any
way there was a prediction that anything
could have happened because there were
so many aeroplanes in the air some
aircrafts and fighter jets there was a
possibility for missiles to fire at us
so we were ready unfortunately because
of a very small decision made by an
individual this tragedy happened all
crowds of students in central Tehran are
protesting the government's response to
the airliner is downing and they chanted
death to the liars and called for the
resignation of those responsible for
shooting down the plane the protests are
in front of Amir Kabir University where
a vigil for the victims had earlier been
helped in a few moments we'll have will
bring in Mike Anna he'll tell us how the
news is likely to go down in Washington
but first we'll speak to Dora Jabari
who's live for us in Tehran to talk us
through the reaction door so now that
there has been an admission well there
is a lot of anger the year Iranian here
are demanding justice and accountability
and many of the people have spoken to
including families of the victims here
are just in shock they don't understand
why their government would have lied to
them for this long
they're demanding those be accountable
we know that the head of their own
judiciary has asked for all the evidence
to be passed on for them to start their
investigation into why this happened we
also know that the head of her
Revolutionary Guards will be going to
Parliament on Sunday to brief MPs about
the chain of events that led to the
downing of this plane by a missile by
the Revolutionary Guards we've also been
seeing pictures of a vigil that took
place outside of Amir Kabir University
in Tehran earlier on Saturday and those
vigils quickly turn into protest and
we've been hearing a chance calling for
the Revolutionary Guards to leave the
country calling the liars to get out
people demanding that those who are
responsible be held accountable so there
is a sense that there is a large amount
of anger among the average Iranian
that's to be expected given the
circumstances that Iran finds itself in
now
all right so dorsa thank you for that
update from Tehran let's get reaction
from Mike on adjoining us from
Washington and during that press
conference Mike by the Revolutionary
Guard Iran did say that the shooting
down occurred in the midst of
hostilities with the United States so
has there been any official reaction
from the presidents himself on what has
come out of Iran there's been no
official reaction whatsoever given the
Iranian acknowledgment of being
responsible for the shooting down of
that airliner the president's been
occupied this morning tweeting about a
domestic issues about his coming
impeachment no reference on his social
media to the Iranian reaction there's
been no official statement from State
Department so certainly it would appear
to be at the stage an error
aura of restraint as far as the trans
administration is concerned not at the
stage responding to the Iranian
explanation about the context in which
the shooting down took place all right
my kind of thank you for that update
from Washington